what do you think of critics who go out
of their way to bash movies is that
being brutally honest and people just
tell it like it is or is there an
element of wanting to wound somebody
it depends on the person
I feel like there's
certain critics
who literally have an out
for certain filmmakers certain producers
certain actors
that no matter what they do
they won't give them like an inch it's
just like ah this guy
you know you always hear the the
expression white man keeps falling
upward you know and I mean the industry
is very guilty of that right like
there's there's a lot of
white men in this industry who have made
some really shitty movies that just keep
getting to make shitty movies
and
I think it's okay to call people out if
they kind of proven themselves time and
time again like if you're going like
past a three or four time and you're
like still making a something that's not
good and we kind of have this you know
Universal decision
that like this is not a good movie and
you're not a good director maybe it's
time to push that person aside and give
someone else
but I do feel like
a good actor
could meet a good director
and it could be
a game changer
someone who like has been bad
as an actor
could have a great script with a gray
filmmaker and they could turn that
person to a star
I mean there's so many people
like within comedy
um I I really don't like the way the
comedy has become over the last like
decade where everything's kind of like
over sexualized and it's grossed out
humor and like
[ __ ] in buckets and forwarding and
all this stuff like all these like kids
playing with dildos all this like really
like grotesque like infantile stuff and
you know people have been embracing it
because like oh now it's females doing
isn't it funny because it's a female
shooting in a bucket it's like nah it
wasn't funny when the guy was doing it
it's definitely not funny when the
woman's doing it like no it doesn't work
but you get to see certain actors like
evolve and I mean
great examples for me are a lot of
comedic actors right
you can take an Adam Sandler or you can
take a Jim Carrey and I'm gonna go use
those two because those are people who I
grew up with and and I love Jim Carrey
but watching Jim Carrey like there's a
bunch of people who hated Jim Carrey and
his brand of humor
right so they're seeing all his movies
they see the ice Ventura ah this is
stupid dumb and dumber such stupid stuff
and then you get to see him in Truman
Show
and you get to see a different side of
him
and it just changes everything you just
you hear your perspective of Jim can't
carry has changed and you see this whole
different sign so Flash Forward to like
recent years
seeing people like Seth Rogen move away
from kind of the Knocked Up thing to do
like more serious dramas or roles that
are comedic but are more mature Jonah
Hill like watching him kind of like in a
super bad and then seeing him in like
Wolf of Wall Street or Moneyball
I couldn't stand Jonah Hill and those
move like super bad and and and uh oh my
God what's the other one like the sitter
all those movies where he was doing all
those comedies and then he said
Moneyball and I'm like who's this guy
like why is he so good and then Wolf of
Wall Street
you really you gotta find it very
interesting you got to give people
chances and they're not you're not
always going to be fan and you may never
be a fan of that person but in the right
hands uh an actor could who you think
might be mediocre or not good could
contract you know transcend everything
you ever thought of that person you
might fall in love with them
so when it comes to critics I think it's
really hard because
I do think that people feel a very
strong Vendetta towards certain
filmmakers or CERN actors
and they they kind of want to poo them
like they always want them to fail and
I'm not saying that that's a big portion
of them but there are definitely people
who like oh you really really hate this
person and every time you see them like
we know Point Blank that this is going
to be a negative reveal I think that's
problematic because in as I said in film
criticism the most important thing to be
is subjective and open-minded you need
to go into anything if a trailer looks
bad if everything looks like it's going
to be terrible even though I'm not
moving and it might surprise you and you
have to admit that you're wrong
and if you like something that other
people don't like you can also admit
that and not be afraid of it because a
lot of people are afraid of not agreeing
what the general consensus
what should matter more to a film critic
being popular or being right
um
probably every video that people are
going to watch is like depends on who
you ask
to me
I don't know I don't really like that
question because
it shouldn't be right
and it shouldn't be about popularity
it should be about
how that movie worked for you and why
why did that movie work why is that a
good movie and explaining why you think
that's a good movie
to me there should be no popularity in
film criticism like you shouldn't and
that that's a problem in itself and a
tangent that I can go on about how
the industry picks
20 people to see stuff always first
and every time they see something it's
either going to be a glowing review or
they won't tweet and to me it's so
problematic and everyone calls them out
and everyone knows and they work for
Outlets that get all the access in the
world
and they can't publicly say it they know
it it's because what people will not
tell you about criticism
is that when you when you work for a
company
that the foundation of your job is built
on selling this stuff
you saying something bad about it and if
it's your job to do the junk it right
afterwards and sit down with the talent
the talent is not going to sit down with
you if you say something is bad or you
really Hammer a movie or you you really
go in on it
they're not and this is something that I
don't know why everyone is so afraid of
so when you unless you're separating the
person doing the interview from the
person who's doing the review
there is unfortunately a bias that is
creative that you can either own up and
say you know what I did not like this
so I'm not going to say anything because
I know I have the junk it
or you just kind of have to like pass
the buck and be like you know what I
feel really strongly about this I really
don't like this so I'm gonna have to
like save my piece
and then if I if it cost me this
it cost me this but there's a financial
thing
and I don't mean to throw any Outlet
underneath the bus but like when you
look at trades whether it's variety
Hollywood Reporter
deadline
or you look at something like Fandango
is the person who works at Fandango
going to screen a movie
and come out of it and say oh that was
terrible
as the initial reaction of like when
he's one of the first people to see it
when he worked for a site whose job it
is to sell tickets
and so many people in this industry are
struggling
that they rely on such dual jobs of like
not just doing criticism anymore but
also like pitching a story to do a
write-up of like the behind the scenes
of this movie that
they can't
say things because if they
publicist the personal publicist the
studio publicist sees this they have the
potential of losing it
people want to be moderators
people want to be moderate just get paid
good money to moderate a panel
do you think that person is going to get
the job if they don't like the movie
no so there's there's so many different
layers to everything now and I think
it's just it's it's exposed more because
of all of the stuff that we see right
because of the social media and all this
stuff and you just kind of see the same
names like when we were growing up
when I was growing up and I I you know I
saw a name on a trailer right it didn't
think to me like
why is that same person being quoted all
the time like it was like always the
same couple people and now it's the same
thing where it's the same names you know
so like you almost after a while you
kind of understand like there's people
that they can go to who can kind of say
hey we need a quote give us a quote
so there's just so many aspects of this
industry that are very difficult but
when it comes to being popular versus
being right
I mean I don't think they have any place
in criticism you know because
you're right in your opinion your
opinion is right no one should be able
to change that if you like something you
like something as long as you can
explain why you like something that's
right to who you are as a person and to
be popular I don't know like I again
it's a weird fandom thing like film
critics have their own fandom like I
it's weird now like right like when we
were growing up there was the greats
right we had Leonard Mullen we had Cisco
and Ebert
yeah yeah there was a couple other
people
and they were just about a very small
group because they were kind of ones
that like everyone knew of they had TV
shows or whatever and you you were very
familiar but like now there's so many
and it's like social media like the guy
who runs I don't know I'm again I'm not
trying to like narrow and point things
out but like the guy who runs
comicbook.com like oh my God I love that
guy it's like the guy runs comicbook.com
like his his job is to like talk about
comic book movies and when they're not
that same guy
who's gonna go see
Black Adam and he's going to talk to
Dwayne Johnson
he's not going to be able to come out of
Black Adam and be like oh man that movie
sucks like what am I doing like what a
waste of my time because he knows two
days later he's gonna be sitting down
with Dwayne Johnson talking about it
because that's the next piece of article
that's going on there and and the trades
are even worse because of the fact that
they their whole business is selling ads
and revenues and telling stories
so I I just I my eyes have been opened
and I have forever changed the way I
look at all of this
moving out here I never knew any of this
until I moved out here eight years ago
and that really changed changed how I
view a lot of this stuff and it's very
hard because I try very hard to be a
genuine person and I like what I like
and I and I don't feel bad about what I
like and I and stuff I don't like it's
very hard because you are often
criticized
if you go too hard on something
and it's just again it's my personal
feeling so but I don't go out of the way
there's there's a difference between
people who go out of their way to slam
something over and over and over and
over again someone else likes it enjoy
it that's fine I just want my peace and
if someone asks me about I'm going to
make my my anger or my love of something
very well known
so fairness in the criticism versus just
trying to just constantly bring like
thinking it's your right to bring
someone down because there is that angle
online as well and and so going back to
let's say you talk about Jonah Hill
maybe you weren't the exact fan of him
right and comedic roles but then when
you saw him in two more serious roles
you're like you know what I like this
guy and and it's do you you know did you
go out of your way to slam him I doubt
yeah I mean you don't I mean I think
it's like again it's it's the level of
which you go for it right you can be
very vocal about you don't like a
director you don't like an actor you
don't like a pop star you don't like a
sports figure you don't like whatever
but there's a point there's a crossroads
right when you're going out of your way
like and this is what we were talking
about with trolls
when you go out of your way to start
seeking people
and like tearing them down
and like there are people who I know
who if they don't like something they
will go on everyone's posts social media
Facebook Instagram and be like you're
wrong you suck what are you doing you're
the worst critic ever you're the worst
you know what does this take blah blah
you were bought by Marvel you're brought
by DC you're bought by Star Wars you're
bought by Disney whatever
that's where you cross a line right you
can just say man I totally
saw this differently and I again I think
it's it's something about there's a fine
line like you can be P movies have this
strange
way and I think it's all entertainment
has a strange way of connecting with
people when you see a good movie
and it connects with you you want to get
up you want to
chair you want to celebrate it you want
to tell all your friends to see it you'd
probably you know us weird people who
get obsessed with these things you don't
want to stop talking about it you just
want to keep championing it I mean I I
go back to my Coda example like I saw
that movie at Sundance on a virtual
screening like as soon as I was able to
see it in the theater I saw it in a
theater and then I went to multiple
press events for it whether I was
moderating it or part of it or not I
went back and I saw it and I just
because I wanted to support the movie
and like if people were like oh you're
being such a shield it's like no no
if I was doing this for every Apple
release or every Disney release or every
DC release then I would be a shell
but because I'm literally picking
something that resonated with me that I
love and I want to Champion there's a
difference and that's what people don't
seem to get you can like something that
a company puts out and hate the next
thing and I always use this as a great
example because
I did not like tragedy in Macbeth and
that was the other movie that was Apple
was pushing with Coda and they tried to
get me it to see that movie again and I
told the Reps I will not
watch that movie again and they were
like come on Denzel Washington and I'm
like if I'm going to meet Denzel
Washington for the first time I wanted
to be a movie where I can walk up to him
and be like Denzel you're amazing and
this movie's amazing not like you're
amazing but like can we talk about
training day or something else because I
don't want to talk about this